/ extract is a tool to extract
structured data out of semi structured
documents using examples this here is a
text file that contains citation records
it was copied from a PDF document each
citation is a list of authors followed
by paper title and here but I want to do
here's analyze how many times each
author has been cited in order to answer
that question I need to convert the
semi-structured data into a structured
format / extract will help me do this
the first step is to identify the top
level record i'm going to select the
first one here next I'm going to
highlight the second one the system
tries to learn a program that can
identify more of these records in the
file and highlight them I see was a
bird's-eye viewer here that there's a
couple of gaps record 19 and 29 I'm
going to simply rehi light them a quick
inspection shows me that they're both
now extract it properly now let's try to
extract a list of all authors I'm going
to add a second label and I'm going to
select just the names of the authors
here you can see that the system tries
to infer this field with it other blue
records but it doesn't get it quite
right you can see right away in the
second record it's not correct in
general it may not be easy to find where
the system made the mistake therefore we
have invested into other user
experiences to help the users spot any
of these discrepancies let me show you
this experience the system generates
c-sharp programs which repair fice into
plain English the green field has been
extracted from bluefield by taking a
substring that starts after the first
white space this is correct since the
list of authors indeed starts after the
first white space in all records the
substring extends up to the camel case
in the second line it so happens that
the list of authors ends at the camel
case for the first record but that
wouldn't be the case for all records
therefore we
to correct the program the system learns
not one program but many programs that
are consistent with the examples
provided by the user I can click on the
part that is incorrect and ask it to
show me alternatives turns out that the
next highlighted option is indeed the
correct one going to click that and I
see that the records are now correct
let's now go ahead and extract the
individual authors note that / extract
can also perform nested extraction to
produce a list of lists as an output
let's select here the first author and
then the second one after I provided a
couple of examples flash extractor ectly
identified the list of all authors and
appropriately displays the nested data
in the table note that flash extract
League NORs the word and in the last
yellow field in any blue record however
my intent could as well have been to
split the string by commas in which case
and should be included as part of the
last yellow string in any blue record
either the user can spot the spy
inspection or by looking at the
synthesized program i want to show you
another powerful user interaction that
can help focus the users attention on
any such ambiguities especially when
they occur somewhere in the middle of
the document we call this active
learning where the system is going to
ask questions like to give me this or
did you mean that going to go into
settings and turn on in disambiguation
this auto dialog box after I turn it on
flash extract asked me whether or not I
intended to include and in the output
look at these two examples here the way
/ extract does this is to synthesize
multiple programs that are consistent
with the user examples and then runs all
of these programs on the remaining
document and uses any differences in the
executions of these programs to frame
the question I can now simply select the
choice without and
now I can load the structured data into
Excel and further work with it